meine meinung ist eben keine angst vor
klartext das hat eben einen besonderen
grund weil ich nämlich bei sky gefeuert
worden bin damals war ich zwei
äußerungen getätigt habe die auf twitter
zunächst einmal sehr negativ beurteilt
wurden und dann aus meiner sicht hat
dann der konzern sky viel zu vorschnell
gehandelt und hat mich damals
rausgeworfen und zwar weil ja nicht
jeder genau weiß welche sprüche das
waren ich habe einmal zu sophia thomalla
bezug genommen die hatte ein freund
loris karius der bei union berlin im tor
stand das heißt es ständig im tor
sondern saß auf der bank und ich hab
dann in einem kommentar gesagt naja für
eine kuschel nacht mit sophia thomalla
würde mich auch auf die bank setzen da
hatte ich einen sexismus shitstorm ohne
ende und damals wollte mich schon raus
werfen aber eben auch das finde ich
daneben bitter dass ein so großer
konzern so sich von twitter orientieren
lässt und dadurch schon gehandelt hat
oder haben sie sich damals gesagt naja
wenn doch ein spruch von ihnen kommt von
dem diamond ganz meisten wirklich raus
und dann war eine situation dass ein
japaner aufs tor geschossen hat und da
habe ich dann formuliert das wäre sein
erster treffer in deutschland gewesen
den letzten hat er im land der sozis
erzielt ich muss in beiden fällen sagen
sowie sophia thomalla mit ihr habe ich
telefoniert die haben darüber gelacht
wird gesagt für mich persönlich ist das
ein kompliment ich habe mich gefreut
über den spruch die betroffene also
selbst hat überhaupt nichts dagegen und
bei den japanerinnen japanern war es so
dass die mir geschrieben haben gesagt
wir sind das land der so schön stolz
darauf es ist natürlich so ein bisschen
der hintergrund ist das so sieht man
doppelt deutlich bewerten kann man kann
damit all die köstlichkeiten meinen dass
ich natürlich gemeint habe man kann aber
auch abfällig damit japaner gemeint
haben aber das lag mir total fern und
völliger blödsinn wie sowas zu
unterstellen und dann hätte ich
eigentlich gesagt ist keine
professionelle einstellung gewünscht hat
sie aber nicht gezeigt ja wir
natürlich mehr häufig gehört dass
die toleranz
zu schlecht und die toleranz polizei in
ein unternehmen muss nächstes jahr auch
so ähnlich gegangen nicht als ich mich
kritisch zum klima entweder der
klimaentwicklung geäußert habe mich auch
gefeuert worden wo sie glaubten bei der
deutschen wildtier stiftung habe ich
gesagt es gibt natürlich auch
natürlichen einfluss auf das klima ist
doch jedem geläufig ist hat auch bereits
lang gefeiert oder gefeuert wird drei
jahren und es ist einfach so weil die
entscheider möchten den schießstand
vermeiden nicht entscheiden möchten
gerne
angepasst sein sozusagen im mainstream
schwimmen und wenn sie aus der
mainstream irgendwo nur ein bisschen
schräg oder
anders auffallend erscheinen dann werden
sie gedeckelt und möglicherweise auch
mit mit
existenznot versehen aber das zeigt eben
eine
wie soll ich sagen eine eine hegemonie
eine eine macht der der der
dem der medien und des mainstreams die
gefährliches warum weil wir solche leute
wie sie oder die anderer meinung sind am
ende brauchen wenn wir nach vorne kommen
wollen es ist ja nicht so dass der menzl
immer recht hat ganz im gegenteil ja
aber er denkt ein kompliment wichtig wer
denkt da war ein kompliment jetzt ist
querdenker das absolute no go das ist
auf der sonst was ja
und wenn wir das nicht wieder
wertschätzen die die abweichende meinung
der kritik und aber auch mal in den witz
und vor allen dingen der wird also ich
finde es ist was was wirklich als erstes
beerdigt worden ist das eigentlich der
humor in der debatte oder dass man
eigentlich überhaupt kein scherz mehr
machen kann dass alle über empfindlich
sind ja wir haben irgendwie so eine
pussy generationen die die einfach
nichts mehr erträgt mir viel aber gerade
ein weil sie jetzt irgendwie meint man
hat sie also gefeuert weil sie japaner
als susis bezeichnet haben
sie haben diesen begriff
gott wir haben unsere regierung ist
gerade dabei eine antidiskriminierungs
beauftragte ins amt zusätzlich die offen
die deutschen als charakter von
österreich und berichte und das scheint
irgendwie kein skandal zwar seien sie
sollten sie schon bald wieder einklagen
das ist einfach traurig oder
emotional also ich hab gerade überlegt
also wie es für mich wäre ich habe mich
in ihre lage versetzt versucht mir ist
ja noch nicht passiert habe ja wie
furchtbar ist für mich wäre wenn ich
hier irgendwie salopp was sage und dann
plötzlich axel springer sagt gut beides
würde mich ehrlich gesagt in den
grundfesten erschüttern wir reden über
sport ja auch nicht immer irgendwas
nicht ja sehr überrascht weil das ist
auch mir meine kollegen moderatoren und
kommentatoren sind supertypen aber in
der führungsspitze sage ich immer mit
amateuren gewinnt so kann die champions
league es sind wirklich leute die auch
unlustig sind die einfach kein humor
selbst haben die haben einen knick
herausgebracht was man sagen darf was
man nicht sagen darf da fahren
man darf sich farbige sagen man soll
aber sagen people of colour wo man eben
sagen mein gott wo ist der unterschied
über über gender da
meinung dazu finde ich ja ganz
fürchterlich ehrlich ich bin ein gegner
von gender ich sage aber immer ich
respektive die leute die gender nur die
leute die gendern sollen mich nicht zu
zwingen zu gendern die sollen mir auch
die freiheit lassen weiterhin zu sagen
80.000 zuschauer im signal iduna park
und ich möchte dich sagen die zuschauer
wir haben das schwere im kopf und
überlegen sich jetzt genau was sie sagen
das schöne ist dass ich wirklich einen
sehr großen zuspruch erhalten habe auch
von kommentatoren von anderen sender
béla réthy zdf tom bartels ard marcel
reif
der geschätzte bild kollege und so
weiter und so fort von vielen leuten
wirklich unterstützen selbst eltern hat
sich dann in einem video für mich stark
gemacht hat gesagt wo sind wir denn
eigentlich hier warum was darf man
überhaupt noch in deutschland sagen wir
übertreiben einfach in deutschland ich
lebe zum großen teil in spanien und da
zb sagt man zu kindern sagt man - das
ist der männliche begriff man sagt aber
entspannen nicht - in linie um kinder
beim er sowohl in der aber bei uns wird
das eben übertrieben aus meiner sicht
und wir sollten einfach mal wieder ein
bisschen runterfahren es kann ja auch
existenzen zerstören wenn das jetzt vor
allem vielleicht auch jüngere kollegen
trifft die auch noch nicht vorgesorgt
haben oder noch nichts anfangen konnten
was könnte man denn dagegen tun also gab
es von ihrer seite irgendetwas was noch
sie hätten tun können um gegen sky zu
gewinnen außerhalb des öffnens zu
springen das war ja ohnehin unnötig weil
mein vertrag lief aus deswegen war das
purer aktionismus das was sie gesagt
haben die wollen sich einfach nur selbst
schützen davor die aber was ich denen
einfach vorwerfe weil skype skype
führung dass sie einfach sich von
twitter so leiten lassen sie sollen
einfach mal abwarten jeder der schon mal
schützt uns erlebt hat
2002 wird neuen fall von nils kaben beim
zdf ein interview mit toni kroos geführt
hat war ein bild auch ein großes thema
weil er sehr negativ gefragt hatte eben
nach dem champions-league-sieg da hatte
auch nichts haben sehr viel shitstorm
abbekommen da hat der redaktionschef
gesagt thomas fuhrmann leute lasst doch
mal die kirche im dorf und beruhigt euch
mal wieder dass er hat sicherlich nicht
glücklich formuliert aber war auch von
toni kroos da überreagiert an dort so
nimmt er eben viel aus den segeln raus
und so hätte ich mir das auch von sky
gewünscht hätte ich das als kairos
gemacht naja ich hoffe dass ich eines
tages gefeiert werden dann
doch so gewesen
ich finde gerade wenn es wenn es
medienanstalten wenn das sender sind
wenn das zeitungen sind muss man doch
genau muss man ja gerade eigentlich auch
die eigenen leute verteidigen und auch
das freie wort verteidigen denn ich
sagen wir machen uns ja unseren eigenen
job kaputt also wenn wenn quasi weil man
etwas diesen chilling effect auf also
dass man sie feiert ist ja im prinzip
kühlt auch die kollegen runde und sagt
er vorsichtig weise raum nächste
eigentlich ja und man schneidet sicher
als medienbetrieb in der haigerlocher
jörn ein wenn nicht mehr gereicht
scanner und und die sägen offen an ihrem
eigenen ast die sägen an ihrem eigenen
angst und wenn ich mir das publikum
ankommen ihnen geht es wahrscheinlich
genauso sie haben wahrscheinlich von
ganz normalen menschen wahnsinnig viele
zuschriften bekommen die alle sagen was
soll der schwachsinn und das ist doch
alles völlig in ordnung das heißt die
menschen da draußen denken anders die
wollen wie man so schön sagt frei
schnauze leben und wenn wir nicht mehr
frei schnauze reden können
dass sie die geschichte geteilt habe ich
finde das sehr wichtig